bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver ça vous regarde version d
confiné c'est parti voici le sommaire
comment sauver l'emploi quand la crise
sanitaire a déjà mis plus d'un million
de personnes sur le carreau
syndicats et patronat a été reçu à
l'elysée aujourd'hui pour tenter de
stopper l'hémorragie plusieurs pistes
sont sur la table on en parlera
certaines entreprises font déjà du
chantage à l'emploi de gagner moins pour
garder son job
est ce la solution on en débat ce soir
on le croyait clos
le feuilleton de la chloroquine rebondit
de plus belle et didier rahout jubile la
prestigieuse revue the lancet tu as fait
son mea culpa après avoir publié une
étude très critique sur ce médicament
utilisé dans le traitement du covan
comment cette querelle scientifique est
elle devenue politique pourquoi les élus
si trip sur ce professeur star et que
raconte ce clivage sur l'état de notre
démocratie décryptage à suivre enfin le
jour d'après nouvel épisode de notre
série d'entretiens sur les conséquences
de l'épidémie
ce soit l'éthique médicale qui doit
vivre et qui doit mourir en cas de
pénurie de ressources à l'hôpital les
céistes frédéric leicester flac
spécialiste des quatre conscience a
répondu à nos questions voilà pour le
programme hashtags réveillère cvr vous
le savez ça n'a pas changé au delà
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
c'est la première fois qu'il se retrouve
physiquement à l'elysée après deux mois
de visioconférence vous ne voyez
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
étaient reçus par emmanuel macron et le
gouvernement ça a duré trois heures de
réunion à bonne distance avec à la
sortie quelques propositions pour sauver
l'emploi est une priorité
favoriser l' embauche de jeunes à 30 y
écouter la première mesure c'est une
prime pour permettre l'embauché des
apprentis que les entreprises continuent
à former les apprentis
même si elles sont aujourd'hui dans un
moment un peu difficile
le coût d'un apprenti sera donc quasi
nulles la première année pour toutes les
embauches entre le 1er juillet et le 28
février l'année prochaine et on va
revenir dans le détail sur ces
différentes mesures avec vous marie le
bec bonsoir vous êtes député la
république en marche des yvelines et
vous dialoguez ce soir avec yves veyrier
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
le secrétaire général de force ouvrière
et vous sortez tout juste de l'elysée
vous nous direz comment ça s'est passé
bon soin benoît c'est remercie d'être là
vous êtes vice président de
l'association nationale des drh vous
faites un métier difficile certains
diront le sale bourde en ces temps de
crise vous allez nous expliquer tout
cela juste après le biais le billet que
vous attendez tous de stéphane blakowski
alors ce qui attend les salariés des
entreprises
c'est difficile je crois si j'ai bien
compris c'est parti
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien compris
son fils
bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien compris
myriam le chômage grimpe en flèche
bon en même temps c'est pas très très
difficile à comprendre il suffit de
regarder la courbe de pôle emploi vous
allez la voir
ça c'est la courbe des chômeurs de
catégorie à c'est-à-dire des chômeurs
qui n'ont même pas un petit une petite
activité partielle pour gagner de
l'argent donc ça a augmenté de 7% en
avril et en mars 23 % en avril
au total il ya plus d'un million de
personnes qui se retrouvent donc au
chômage total ça fait plus de quatre
millions et demi de français dans cette
situation et ça c'est un record
historique
alors évidemment ya de quoi s'inquiéter
surtout si on travaille dans un secteur
qui a été très durement touché par la
crise on cite souvent l'aéronautique le
tourisme l'automobile mais il ya
d'autres secteurs concernés regardez un
article qui est publié dans métro fin
mai voyez le titre crise des médias des
licenciements partout dans le monde
oula oula oula 6 à 6,6 à lire si ce
pardon si ça licencie je suis sous le
choc à tout va dans les médias peut-être
qu'on devrait un petit peut s'inquiéter
heureusement heureusement il ya
peut-être une solution pour éviter de se
faire virer ce thread accepté de baisser
son salaire
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a proposé hier
un magnet pénicaud son idée c'est par
exemple ce qu'elles disent qu'il faut se
serrer les coudes donc par exemple si au
lieu de gérer 20 % du personnel dans une
boîte elle elle dit bah si tous les
salariés acceptent de baisser leurs
salaires leurs rémunérations ça permet
d'éviter un plan social massif
alors je vous pose la question myriam
vous est ce que vous seriez prête à
baisser votre salaire inari et venir oui
je sais je sais c'est pas une décision
facile à prendre
pas nous regarder par exemple des
literies payet l'une des vedettes de
l'olympique de marseille
il touche 500 mille euros brut par mois
et il a dit bah non moi je ne baisse pas
mon salaire je suis désolé j'ai une
famille à nourrir
j'ai des crédits à rembourser bah oui on
sait ce que cela myriam mais aussi vous
avez des enfants à nourrir
c'est délicat d'accepter une baisse de
salaire ou pourriez peut-être par
exemple su proposer la direction de
supprimer un poste de chroniqueur
non voilà à nos côtés si ça doit
permettre à l'ouzo moins de manger à
leur faim
je vois pas comment je pourrais refusé
franchement non du canadien il ya une
chose il est chose qui est sûre
c'est que quand vous avez quitté le
parisien il ya deux ans pour revenir sur
lcp ce n'était pas forcément une
mauvaise idée puisque le canard enchaîné
nous apprenait que un plan social est
dans les tiroirs un plan social assez
costaud dans le journal le parisien
on voyait en conclusion je pense que ça
relativise pas mal cette idée de se
serrer les coudes comme disait muriel
pénicaud le parisien c'est la propriété
de bernard arnault à nos plus grands
milliardaires et donc quand il prépare
un plan social
si c'est ça se serrer les coudes selon
la formule de muriel pénicaud route ça
relativise un petit peu le concept
l'enseignement de l'art de l'euphémisme
en politique il fait rien on va revenir
sur ses propositions sur la table et
notamment ces accords de performance qui
permettent de négocier des baisses de
salaire en échange du maintien d'emplois
mais vous sortez la juste à chaud de
cette longue réunion
comment ça s'est passé bien le prion la
république que nous recevait pour la
troisième fois alors cette fois là en
physique mais depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire on a eu de
visioconférence bon moi j'ai compris que
le prix on a république voulait marquer
une étape puisque les sujets sur
lesquels depuis plusieurs semaines on a
eu l'occasion de discuter avec la venue
du travail le ministre de l'économie et
des finances en particulier
ceux de l'accompagnement de la situation
de confinement puis de la situation de
déconfinement d'une reprise progressive
et maintenant la phase reprise de
l'activité normalement long terme
d'accompagnement d'une reprise qui on le
voit bien les progressive partiel et qui
inquiète tout un chacun
le lycée était drôle dans des
négociations au plus haut niveau d'états
ou c'est à dire que c'est une étape
parce que au plus haut niveau de l'état
ça se discute avec les pouvoirs publics
l'exécutif sur les dispositions qui font
l'objet de décisions d'ordre législatif
ou de décrets d'ailleurs à ce sujet
puisque le prion de la république nous
nous appelle à négocier sur ces
questions il a mis quelques sujets sur
la table l'activité partielle de longue
durée ou spécifiques
donc ça il y aura des aides qui seront
prolongées pour l'indemnisation du
chômage en recettes dans certains
secteurs où les toute la question va
être justement de savoir dans quel cadre
et dans quels contextes et moi j'ai
redit une chose si il s'agit de
développer cette petite musique sur la
modération salariale dans un contexte de
difficultés économiques
je pense que c'est une double erreur je
les dis ces jours ci parce que je
sentais les choses venir
c'est une erreur parce que les salariés
concernés alors la chronique était drôle
mais quand vous êtes dans une entreprise
confrontée aux tiraillements maintenant
au début c'était entre le risque de la
maladie et perdre son travail maintenant
c'est toujours un peu quand même le
même un peu beaucoup il faut quand même
y faire attention le risque de la
maladie mais en maintenant le risque de
perdre son travail ou une partie de son
salaire pour les salariés c'est pas
drôle du tout et c'est une double erreur
parce que les salariés n'y sont pour
rien quand même dans cette crise si on a
dû confiner c'est parce qu'on n'avait
pas d'autres moyens faute de
dispositions en termes de dispositions
de protection le moyen en effet aussi
sur la récession et puis international
rossa mais dangereux parce que si c'est
cette musique généralisée c'est un effet
récessif derrière au moment où on a
besoin de tirer l'activité et en france
la demande intérieure reste un facteur
un pendant de l'activité vous demander à
l'état de soutenir au maximum l'emploi
et le pouvoir d'achat les enveloppes
budgétaires
marie lebey que peut faire l'état
franchement dans cette période déjà il
faut regarder ce qui a été fait depuis
le début de la crise il y avait
effectivement un dispositif très fort de
soutien à l'emploi avec l'ouverture de
du chômage partiel de manière très
importante puisqu'elle a permis
d'inclure 12 millions de salariés ça il
faut le maintenir pour tous les secteurs
les plus frappés il faut ce qu'on va
faire c'est celle là c'est la logique
aussi de dire finalement on était dans
une phase de conf de confinement il
fallait protéger les salariés il fallait
accompagner les entreprises face à une
situation qui était absolument inédite
où effectivement on disait pour la
grande majorité des salariés on préfère
protéger de la maladie plutôt que de les
exposer au risque après il ya toujours
les métiers spécifiques notamment de
ceux qui étaient en première ligne et
puis on va rentrer dans une phase de
reprise là on est dedans et ensuite de
relance et il est normal que
progressivement l'état se retire et de
monde aux entreprises de négocier en
interne
finalement des accords qui permettront à
la fois de préserver l'emploi et de
préserver les compétences et je crois
qu'on a passé un message ton détaché par
la crise quand est ce que l'état doit se
retirer parce qu'il y avait une première
étape à partir de juin il y en avait
peut-être une autre
noël janvier est-ce qu'il faut certains
secteurs on leur dise voilà jusqu'à
nouvel ordre on continue de soutenir
on a les charges on annule les uns des
secteurs dans lesquels les je pense
notamment à l'industrie touristique est
peut-être plus spécifiquement aux à la
question des restaurateurs ou
effectivement on a dit on continue de
vous accompagner parce que vous faites
l'objet de mesures réglementaires dont
vous n'êtes pas pour lesquelles vous
n'êtes pas décisionnaire mais pour
lesquelles il s'est donc c'est l'état
qui prendra en charge le quoi qu'il en
coûte pour le moment principalement
selecta le droit qu'ils auront dans
l'est dans ces secteurs là il ya une
garantie effectivement de l'état qui est
apportée dans les autres secteurs et je
crois que c'est un peu les exigences
qu'on demande aujourd'hui aux
entreprises c'est de dire on va se
retirer progressivement on met en place
des mécanismes qui sont innovants je
pense à ce qu'on a voté dans le dernier
texte qui a été débattu à l'assemblée
qui a été adopté hier en lecture
définitive c'est un très visible sur
l'activité
l'activité réduite contre le justement
le maintien de l'emploi nous il faut
notre responsabilité en tant que pouvoir
public est innovant sur les dispositifs
qu'on va mettre d'accompagnement aux
entreprises mais les entreprises la
contrepartie c'est à dire vous avez un
dialogue social qui doit être exigeant
sur savoir comment est-ce qu'on préserve
l'emploi au sein des entreprises parce
que en fait quand vous préserver les
compétences vous temps était aussi de
plus facilement redémarrer votre
régularité qu'on va s'arrêter d'ailleurs
sur le cas de ryan et moi mais juste
serrer les coudes pense que c'est une
idée importante ça renvoie la solidarité
on a parlé pendant la crise
on aimerait que ça durera près mais pour
faire accepter cette idée de d'efforts à
faire ensemble
escapades et mesure au moins symbolique
et même utile à prendre sur la question
des dividendes considérables qui sont
versés dans les plus grandes entreprises
sur la question des salaires
quand on voit que les salaires des
grands patrons du cac40 ça c'est plus de
250 fois le smic est ce que il n'ya pas
des mesures importantes à prendre au
moins pour faire accepter à l'ensemble
des français l'idée qu' on se serre la
ceinture mais tous ensemble moi je pense
que cette interpellation m'étais décidé
absolument daryl vaz mesures qui ont été
présentées je n'ai pas eu la chance
d'être à la conférence à laquelle à ce
qu'est ce que vous avez là une
contribution des hauts revenus par année
ce qui est sûr c'est que depuis début de
la crise on essaye d'être réactif d'être
innovant et donc il y aura peut-être des
mesures qui vont aller dans ce sens
souhaité qu'elles exigent qu'elle existe
je ne sais pas qu'est-ce que vous le
souhaitez personnellement moi je crois à
titre personnel si je regarde par
exemple les annonces qui ont été faites
en matière d'attractivité de la france
de dire ce qui va permettre aussi à un
amant de ce fin se serrer les coudes et
en tout cas de sortir de cette phase et
dire on va faire venir des entreprises
qui ont s'implanter parce que la france
sera un pays attractif parce que les
salariés seront bien formés parce qu'il
y aura des compétences et je crois que
si on arrive à rester dans cette
dynamique de dire on a le monde a
traversé une crise et la france est
toujours là pour attirer des
investisseurs mais les actionnaires
paris 1900 en 1976 briscard d'estaing
avait fait un impôt sécheresse qui fait
les plus hautes catégories de des
salariés escapade exceptionnel d'une
année est ce qu'il n'ya pas une crise
exceptionnelle qui mériterait une taxe
exceptionnelle pas pour plomber
l'attractivité et la compétitivité mais
pour faire participer ce qu'on a
vraiment les moyens
mais dans certains secteurs alors ont
pour l'instant on l'a pas fait peut-être
sur les questions de répartition de la
richesse bien qu'on ait encouragé les
dispositifs d'intéressement par exemple
dans les entreprises mais je crois que
inde est une des réponses par exemple
qu'on a pu apporter c'est en de demander
pour les secteurs je pense l'automobile
je pense notamment à air france d'hier
bien sûr l'état va venir en soutien et
c'est normal cdc un nombre d'emplois qui
est considérable et des compétences etc
mais on veut nous demandent des
garanties en matière d'environnement et
c'est ce qui est c'est ce qu'a demandé
bruno le maire c'est vrai signés soit
libre et pourrait refroidir pas
forcément vrai pour renault sur l'emploi
mais je voudrais qu'on s'arrête puisque
vous parlez des modérations salariales
et puis je vous donne la parole tout de
suite après benoît serre sur ce cas de
ryanair on baisse vos salaires ou alors
vous êtes licencié c'est exactement en
substance ce qu'ont compris les quelques
200 salariés français de la compagnie
low cost irlandaise
ils ont reçu une lettre comme nous
l'expliquent rabique à baisser son
salaire de 10% pour ne pas être licencié
c'est la nouvelle trouvaille de la
compagnie aérienne ryanair pour dit-elle
préserver l'emploi de ces 250 salariés
français une proposition jugée
inacceptable pour les syndicats
prévenus par un simple mail le 15 mai
dernier
soit vous signer cet accord de réduction
soit nous serons obligés de licencier
c'est du chantage tout à fait c'est une
compagnie qui a eu un milliard de
bénéfices l'année dernière il n'y a
aucune compagnie aérienne au niveau de
l'union européenne qui est en capacité
d'afficher de tels montants de bénéfices
donc un milliard c'est pas rien du tout
et en plus ils ont plusieurs milliards
de cash aussi sur lesquels ils
pourraient ils pourraient véritablement
se reposer pour traverser cette crise et
pour montrer un tout petit peu de
respect à leurs salariés
on pourrait se dire 10% qu'est ce que
c'est mais enfin c'est quand même plus
un peu plus de 100 euros pour des
personnes qui gagnent 100 euros faire
des sacrifices pour sauver son emploi
avant ryanair plusieurs entreprises
l'ont imposé à leurs salariés
et cela n'a pas empêché les
licenciements 2009 une usine continental
de clairoix s'embrase
la direction vient d'annoncer la
fermeture du site alors que les employés
avaient accepté deux ans plus tôt de
passer à 40 heures par semaine
même colère même sentiment de trahison
chez goodyear à amiens
eux aussi avaient accepté de travailler
plus pour finalement perdre leur emploi
après six ans de bataille judiciaire un
peu plus de 800 ex salariés viennent
d'obtenir des dommages-intérêts pour
licenciement abusif
aujourd'hui la crise liée aux
coronavirus pousse les entreprises à
demander des concessions à leurs
employés sous peine de licenciement
une méthode dénoncée par le gouvernement
puisqu'ils ont eu du chômage partiel
pour préserver les emplois je trouve
qu'ils ne jouent pas le jeu
il faut qu'il corrige la copie et
pourtant trois ans plus tôt la ministre
défende et les ordonnances travail et
leur accorde performance collective
ils permettent aux entreprises en cas de
difficultés financières de baisser les
salaires et d'augmenter le temps de
travail pour une durée maximale de cinq
ans alors je m'adressais à benoît c'est
reconnaît évidemment au parker le droit
du travail
est-ce que c'est légal ce café ryanair
n'est pas le détail de ce don par
portage
l'accord de casamance collective c'est
effectivement mais il ya dès lors que
ceux négociés faut pas perdre de vue il
verrier le sait bien que l'accord de
performance collective c'est un accord
majoritaire dont qui nécessite un accord
avec les partenaires sociaux est ce que
ryanair a fait ce choix je ne sais pas
où est ce qu il a fait un choix d'écrire
à chacun de ses salariés pour obtenir
leur accord individuel pour baisser
leurs salaires
je ne suis pas convaincu que ce soit la
meilleure des méthodes qu'ils utilisent
et qu'il peut y avoir dans certains cas
à baisser les salaires dans la période
dans certaines entreprises ça peut être
ou en double ou un effet nécessité quand
saddam était double il doit pouvoir être
encadrés et jeune j'écoutais le débat
juste avant je pense que les pouvoirs
publics doivent plutôt intervenir pour
développer des systèmes qui permettent
de trouver les accords avec les horreurs
dont du personnel plutôt qu'aller
chercher toujours taxer ceci ou cela je
pense que le sujet il est là est la
bonne
ces accords collectifs
comment s'appelle-t-il déjà de
performance pardonnez moi ils sont
temporaires ils sont négociés avec les
partenaires sociaux pour une durée
limitée quelles sont les conditions il
faut une baisse de l'activité bien seul
la première des conditions c'est qu'ils
font 10 soit majoritaire c'est à dire
que vous devez signer avec plus de 50%
des représentants du personnel et ça
c'est un élément très important
ils sont issus du travail ils permettent
de remettre en cause pendant un temps
déterminé qu'ils ne peuvent pas dépasser
cinq ans à la fois où le temps de
travail en l'augmentant où la
rémunération sachant quelquefois en fait
on ouvre dans le temps de travail sans
augmenter de la même valeur la
rémunération ce qui signifie la bce est
derrière ces gens travaillent aussi pour
une somme inférieure
il peut organiser un certain nombre d
éléments de mobilité il a une
conséquence c'est que dès lors qu'il ait
signé qu'un salarié refuserait de se
soumettre à ce qui est prévu à cet
accord il est licencié ce qui s'appelle
sui generis donc cesser une distorsion
un peu particulier donc c'est sans doute
cela mais je crois que c'est pas du
chantage que d'une certaine façon ça
n'est pas du chantage d'une certaine
façon parce que s'il n'est pas s'y
attendait il ya deux choses
si c'est signé par les partenaires
sociaux on peut pas appeler ça du
chantage
si effectivement ces branches chaque
individu lui dire soit une baisse la
rémunération soit est licencié alors ça
ressemble diablement et du chantage mais
juste un poil moins une minute
l ai dit je crois performance collective
sont intéressants si on y ajoute une
disposition qui serait de comment on en
sort parce que ça quelquefois comment on
en sort c'est juste de redonner aux gens
le salaire qu'ils avaient or c'est assez
injuste puisque les gens font un effort
pour sauver l'entreprise et lui permet
de retrouver la rentabilité
quel est le mode par lequel ils vont
gagner une partie cette rentabilité
retrouvée autrement dit le partage de la
valeur créée par l'effort qu'ils ont
fait une manière intelligente de passer
sa crise mais de faire que demain les
salariés par le biais de l'intéressement
la participation que vous voyez chalet
ailleurs un bon baisse le salaire pour
un temps mais on leur et augmente
davantage quand l'activité revient y
verriez vous êtes patron de force
ouvrière
vous êtes près mon signe de force
secrétaire général vous en avez déjà
signé non la confédération ne signe pas
certains syndicats ont signé dans les
entreprises n'ont jamais signé dans
certaines entreprises les syndicats ont
négocié parfois signé des accords de
performance et préfèrent aujourd'hui
dans le contexte nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur le principe maintenant nos
syndicats défendre les salariés leurs
emplois leurs rémunérations dans les
conditions dans lesquelles ils se
trouvent confrontées à un principe de
réalité
c'est pas un principe de réalité c'est
ça dépend beaucoup du secteur d'activité
de l'entreprise elle-même mais ce sont
systématiquement si on n'appelle pas ça
du chantage de toute façon des
négociations dos au mur où vous avez en
perspective soit des suppressions
d'emplois soit des efforts que vous
devez faire
le cac qui était mentionné celui
d'augmenter le temps de travail sans
augmenter le salaire en mémoire pas très
loin derrière nous c'était smart smart
ils sont passés de 35 à 39 heures au
salaire de 35 heures et quelques années
plus tard ils ont été délocalisée en
chine il ya une proposition sur la table
peut-être que il voulait fait tout à
l'heure à à l'elysée elle est signée de
du medef geoffroy roux de bézieux qui
propose de demander à l'état de
compenser les baisses de salaire en cas
de baisse d'activité de 40 %
c'est-à-dire une sorte d'adaptation de
ces accords de performance qui
permettrait au fonds de ne pas être
voilà pénalisé par les parlers
modération salariale mais ça n'est pas
l'employeur qui paye il y a alors c'est
toute la question de ce dispositif
d'activité partielle le chômage partiel
spécifique ou de londres vient du lycée
marcel de loups à l'arrêt mais n'oubliez
pas qu'aujourd'hui dans la législation
c'est durant la période de confinement
les entreprises ont été indemnisé à 100%
jusqu'à quatre et demi le smic les
salariés eux n'ont jamais été indemnisés
qu'à 70 % du brut 84 % du net
sachant que tous les éléments de
rémunération sont pas pris en compte sa
fait en général plutôt 20 % de perte de
salaire à la fin donc sur le delta qui
seraient pris en charge par l'activité
partielle
s'il n'y a pas de sensation au delà de
ce que prend en charge l'état par
l'entreprise elle-même
les salariés vont perdre du pouvoir
d'achat je le redis ce serait une grave
erreur que de donner ce signal un peu
général de la nécessité de modérer les
salaires parce que ça ne donne pas
confiance ça n'incite pas à consommer et
c'est pas comme ça qu'on ira surtout
vous rappelle la moitié de la population
salariée est en dessous de 1800 euros
net par mois quand vous perdez quelques
dizaines d'euros voire centaines d'euros
sur la rémunération la femme est
différente et n'a remis au restaurant ni
a fortiori vous n'achèterez une des
quatre cent mille voitures qui ont été
construites qui n'ont pas été vendus du
fait du confinement est ce que vous
répondez mari l'a d'ailleurs aussi une
chose hein parce que dans cette réunion
cet après-midi
moi j'attendais aussi une réponse sur
cette question notamment pour tout les
salariés de ce qu'on appelait la
deuxième ligne aile ségur de la santé
pour la santé
mais toutes les caissières les agents
des entreprises de propreté les
manutentionnaires les transporteurs les
est beau et c'est tout ce dont on a
parlé qui s'était révélé essentielle qui
ne se sont jamais arrêtés
on s'attendait à ce que on nous fasse
une annonce peut-être pas d'augmentation
comme ça aujourd'hui des salaires mais
au moins qu'on engage une négociation
sur la façon dont on repositionne ses
professions et ça pour le moment j'ai
pas dresser vrai que si ces invisibles
ces deuxièmes lignes ne sont pas
valorisées et qu'il y a des modérations
salariales de fait dans les secteurs les
plus touchés c'est c'est perdant-perdant
pour vraiment tout le monde mais déjà
juste pendant sur les accords de
performance collective quand même
rappeler que en fait souvent on regarde
ryanair en garde renault les en plus les
chiffres sont extrêmement importants
donc c'est aussi des c'est anxiogène
c'est effrayant mais faut pas oublier
que les accords de performance
collective depuis qu'ils existent donc
depuis 2010 est il y en avait quand même
eu 300 de signer ça permet aussi à des
entreprises dans lequel il ya un
dialogue social qui est aussi peut-être
plus de proximité si on pouvait les
exprimer ainsi de continuer à faire
évoluer en fonction des difficultés pour
rencontrer son secteur d'activité où son
entreprise pendant un temps ensuite le
deuxième point c'est que j'entends tout
ce qui est dit sur les salariés sur le
fait de dire il ne faut pas que les
salariés payent mais on a on peut avoir
des accords de performance collective
mais on a aussi mis en place au cours
des différents textes de lois qui ont
été étudiées pendant cette période
la reconduction de ce qui a un moment
été appelé la prime macron en fait cette
prime de 1000 euros que vous pouvez
donner à vos salariés ils auraient base
du volontariat des succès de
l'entreprise
vous savez moi j'ai bougé beaucoup de
bouchons à 0 moi j'ai eu beaucoup
d'entreprises pendant cette période de
confinement et tous m'ont dit oui on est
d'accord parce que effectivement quand
vous avez des caissières quand vous avez
des agents d'entretien qui sont venus
qui ont qui se sont déplacés qui parfois
ont des moyens de transport qui sont pas
forcément facile on a envie de
jouer je garde un oeil très rapidement
pour terminer et est très rapidement et
on a aussi et dans la loi pacte est là
encore dans le texte
georges confirmer la dynamique qu'on
essayait de créer en matière de création
de d'intéressement et ça c'est aussi un
moyen de rémunération pour les salariés
c'est s'il faudra aller beaucoup plus
loin sur l'intérêt voilà c'est mais
c'est du plus long terme mais on est je
voudrais une petite question est une
toute petite réponse rapide peut-être
que vous serez d'accord là dessus
la réforme d'assurance chômage on
n'applique pas surtout pas on arrête
ben ça c'est notre demande mais je n'ai
pas la réponse pour le moment moi
j'avais il faut qu'on attendait pas eu
de réponse la réforme de juin 2019 qu'on
revienne à la convention qui avait été
négocié en 2017 et qui courait jusqu'en
2022 toutefois se mettre d'accord pour
moi la suspendre par mois là suspense
puisque effectivement le sens de cette
réforme c'est à dire les chiffres du
chômage s'améliore donc on fait des
dispositifs qui permettent effectivement
d'un peu plus incitations dans le retour
à l'emploi et là on doit être doré une
dynamique plus protectrice est très
clair merci infiniment d'être venu sur
le plateau d'ally cp pour ce débat on va
parler à présent de celui qui est devenu
le visage de cette crise sanitaire le
professeur didier raoult adulé ou
détesté il a donné en tous les cas le
tempo médiatique avec ses chloroquine à
cette épidémie entraînant d'ailleurs
avec lui les politiques qu'on
n'attendait pas franchement sur ce
terrain clément pernot
l'hydrochlorothiazide dicaments miracle
contre le coc vide 19 certains
politiques semblent y croire dès les
premières semaines de la crise sanitaire
à les écouter alors le temps presse il
n'y a pas une minute à perdre
lorsque comme le dit le président de la
république la guerre est déclarée
on n'a pas le temps d'expérimenter sur
des souris pendant six mois et à partir
du moment où il y à une solution testée
déjà sur un certain nombre de patients
qui semblent porter leurs fruits
je ne vois pas pourquoi la france se
priveraient tenez à tous les médecins de
ville
la capacité de prescrire à ceux qui sont
contaminés avec des symptômes plus
graves
cette que rocky ainsi on peut obtenir le
serait ce que 10 % de baisse des cas
graves
eh bien ça veut dire qu'on fera pas
obligé de trier les gens on est là
tout de suite la prescription et le
directeur général de la santé dit tout
de suite à tous les hôpitaux 30 à
l'église toute façon qu'est ce qu'on
risque questions j'en meurs les gens
meurent les gens meurent cet emballement
politique inattendue pour ce médicament
n'a pas été du goût de tous les médecins
leur opinion il fallait pas la donner en
public ou en tout cas elle ne fait pas
autorité parce que là on est sur une
affaire scientifiques etc là on a viré
complètement dans une affaire au delà
même du politique on était vraiment dans
une affaire émotionnelle dans une
affaire de deux médias quasiment de
showbiz
on n'est pas en train de parler bonbons
ou de couleur de cheveux on est en train
de parler de médicaments avec
potentiellement des risques mais au delà
du médicament c'est aussi son grand
défenseur le professeur raoul ce qui
fascine les politiques
didier raoult était trop mal aimé par
les belles personnes pour ne pas
éveiller l'intérêt surtout quand sa part
des amis de madame busin donc le monde
entier par les mets en pratique les
travaux du professeur raout mais en
france on le met sous surveillance c'est
quoi le loup là dedans
et même après la mise en cause de son
traitement par la revue the 27
les défenseurs politique du professeur
n'en démordent pas didier raoul tu sais
le sanitairement incorrect voit là et il
est là il est peut-être à la médecine ce
que nous nous sommes à la politique
c'est à dire politiquement incorrect et
surtout il fait ressortir une parole qui
n'est peut-être pas celle qu'il n'est
peut-être pas celle de la doxa olivier
ferrand a été trop rapide à interdire ce
traitement il s'est dépêché comme s'il y
avait une espèce de vengeance contre le
professeur out je dénonce la façon dont
il a été traité
quant au principal intéressé il se
défend d'avoir chercher à politiser ces
travaux on le voit bien c'est avec cette
statine des gens qui sont censés être
intelligente d'un coup des raisons des
réactions passionnelles chaque fois
qu'on dit quelque chose ça ne témoigne
pas du fait que l'on est de gauche ou de
droite ou de ceci ou de cela on a le
droit d'être subtil ce débat enflammé ne
s'est pas limitée aux plateaux télé et
aux réseaux sociaux il a aussi eu des
conséquences concrètes sur le terrain
fait les patients quand je les vois aux
urgences il y avait les pour out qui me
disait je veux de la chloroquine et les
antis raul tu qui eux
suivez les recommandations et nous mêmes
médecins prescripteurs ça nous amène
dans une salle nous a mis dans une
situation extrêmement difficile qui est
quasiment un an
aux droits des patients qui était
l'exigence thérapeutique en dix ans
estrosi il a dit ça donc moi je veux le
même médicament
oui on est dans un truc qui est
complètement fou parce que irrationnelle
qui peut être dangereux la crise de
confiance entre les français et leur
politique c'est donc répandue jusque
dans les hôpitaux et les cabinets de
médecins
bonsoir emmanuel rivière soit merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes directeur
général de kantar publiques france et
vous venez de publier un baromètre qui
nous a particulièrement intéressé c'est
le dernier baromètre politique dans
lequel pour le figaro magazine dans
lequel didier rahout fait son apparition
propulsé directement la troisième place
derrière roselyne bachelot et olivier
vers en test d'opinion sur les
personnalités politiques ces petits
trains qui ont le mieux géré la crise on
va le commenter dans un instant et puis
nous sommes en duplex avec laurent
alexandre bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes essayiste médecins et
fondateur de doctissimo va commencer
juste avec ce sondage déjà personnalités
politiques on s'étonne olivier derand
roselyne bachelot bruno le maire de
nicolas hulot xavier bertrand c'est une
personnalité politique s'est dit raúl
est une personnalité dans le contexte un
peu ce qu'on aime qui peut détourner les
questions qu'on pose depuis 40 ans pour
le figaro magazine
en demandant aux gens ce qu'ils pensent
de latitude constitue un certain nombre
de personnalités et donc pas forcément
politique face à la crise du coureur et
virus cela dans la présence de didier
roux dans cette liste et pas finalement
usurpé parce que là sa structure d'image
est assez politique d'abord il est très
clivant salariés effectivement dans les
premiers rangs de ceux dont on dit il a
une bonne attitude
mais il se trouve que ces 26 % il se
trouve qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de gens
27% qu'il dise qu'il a eu une mauvaise
attitude est un jeune arabe quand on met
une personnalité de la société civile
on n'a pas ce genre de clivage on a des
gens plutôt épargné et pas très connu ça
c'est une autre caractéristique de
dia haute mais ça n'étonnera personne il
est beaucoup plus connu qu'un grand
nombre de personnalités politiques dans
cette ligue mais l'avoir mis dans cette
liste est ce que ça lui offre pas un
tremplin au fond être qu'il n'en a pas
besoin mais supplémentaires tout de même
oui je crois que c'est plus je crois que
c'est plutôt l'inversé
le sondage constate me vient confirmer
ce que je n'avais pas besoin déjà de
tremplin alors qu'est ce qu'ils
voulaient comment vous expliquer cette
popularité alors ce qui ce qui plaît
chez lui en fait mais on remercie de
m'avoir invité à me pencher plus sur lui
que sur d'autres personnalités notre
enquête parce que ça m'a mis en évidence
quelque chose en fait son image est bien
meilleure à la fois chez ceux qui sont
très inquiet par l'épidémie et ceux qui
ne le sont pas du tout ce qui peut
paraître mystérieux hommes en fait ça
invite peut-être à compléter ce qu'on a
déjà beaucoup dit sur divers où il plaît
parce qu'il a des certitudes dans cette
période d'incertitude
il sait et donc il rassure ceux qui ont
besoin de se rapprocher à desservir tout
comme finalement il plaît à ceux qui en
ont eux mêmes de certitude qu'ils sont
qui sont pas du tout cela représentait
un espoir avec son traitement dentaire
d'espoir mais voilà il ya dans cette
forme alors mais par ailleurs il ya
d'autres formes qui plaisent on voit
qu'ils doivent philippe est très
favorisés dans ce sondage qui était
plutôt sur une ligne qui consiste à dire
on ne sait pas on devra expérimenter
éventuellement adaptée etc
mais il se trouve que voilà digard
otilia cela et puis il y à aussi
effectivement par leurs caractéristiques
d'un personnage un peu trublion atypique
qui va forcément attirer la lumière à la
fois lors abus du scientifique puis
quelque chose qui à mon avis déplaît pas
dans le caractère séduction du
personnage cette manière plus ou moins
feutrée qui l'a de dire qu'à part lui
tous les autres n'ont rien compris sa
partie aussi de son attrait alors je
vais vous dire juste après si on peut
cerner par appartenance politique les
comment dire l'adhésion à la popularité
de didier raoult mais d'abord laurent
alexandre elle vous surprend cette
popularité franchement on pas du tout
toute la stratégie actuelle de
de raoul tête une stratégie politique
d'ailleurs son rapprochement avec onfray
dans front populaire et bien signe qu'il
a décidé de labourer l'extrême
popularité qu'il a dans certains cercles
populiste et shelly gilet jaune alors
c'était pas une étude kantor mais
c'était une étude ifop qu'il ya un mois
et demi
montrer que didier raoul séduisait 80%
des gens qui se reconnaissent gilet
jaune donc en cours et de gilet jaune
isation de la médecine
qu'est ce que ça veut pas dire qu'on ne
fait plus de la médecine dans les
grandes revues scientifiques entre
médecins on l'a fait sur les réseaux
sociaux et on affirme tous les autres
sont des cons on humilie les
journalistes qui ne sont pas d'accord
avec vous regardez la façon dont de raul
tu as traité pujadas en lui expliquant
qu'il ne pouvait pas comprendre qu'elle
n'était pas possible
la dass comprennent des choses
compliquées parce qu'ils n'étaient pas à
la hauteur mais on a vu pour bien
comprendre ce que vous lui reprochez
c'est son style son côté anti système le
fait qu'ils s'attaquent un an de façon
très de comptables aux journalistes ou
c'est le fait d'avoir prescrit ce
médicament dans son dans son hôpital à
marseille
l'acro l'origine qui a à l'heure où l'on
se parle
rien ne démontre qu'elle est dangereuse
ou pas pour pour la santé dans lequel
richard house c'est d'avoir fait faire
un grand pas en arrière à la
méthodologie scientifique
c'est dire qu'on à se croire aux gens
qu'il y avait un remède miracle alors
que pour évaluer une nouvelle stratégie
thérapeutique il faut au minimum six
mois
mais aujourd'hui on n'a toujours aucun
traitement à part le paracétamol dans
les formes légères et la réanimation
dans les formes graves on n'a toujours
aucun médicament lui l'horizon pardonnez
moi de vous un terrain mais illustrait
la pousserait défendre alors alexandre
lui vous réponds qu'on est en situation
de guerre etc en situation de guerre on
soigne alors que en situation de paix on
étudie on cherche mais le temps n'est
pas le même et qu'il fallait absolument
traité traité traité up absolument
absolument pas des traitements qui
aggravent la situation des malades on en
a connu beaucoup dans le land dans
l'histoire très souvent notre intuition
médicale à nous médecins elle et elle
est fausse dans le traitement de
l'infarctus il y avait un consensus de
sang pur
100 des cardiologues sur terre pour
penser qu'il fallait mettre des anti
arythmique et le jour où on a fait un
essai clinique gars plus placebo
on s'est rendu compte que le médicament
multipliait le risque de mourir par 2,7
par rapport au placebo alors que 100%
des cardiologues pensait que le
médicament était très efficace dans
l'infarctus
cette stratégie médicamenteuse à pompe à
saint brès versus placebo a tué plus que
la guerre du vietnam aux etats-unis elle
a tué soixante mille américains donc
l'avant et l'excellent de real elle est
très fortement trompeuses
il faut donc être vigilant et c'est pour
ça qu'on a des méthodologies
d'évaluation du médicament si l'on
parvient fait une étude suffisamment
large et suffisamment légitime puisqu'on
sait que la dernière en date qui était
une vaste étude de la prestigieuse revue
britannique the lancet tu as été
finalement critiqué par par 127 lui même
ça c'est pas un essai clinique le long
set c'est une observation dossier qui
est tout à fait critiquable la seule le
seul essai clinique ont à ce titre
prospectif en tirant au sort les malades
c'est l'étude qui a été publiée hier
dans le new england journal of medecine
et qui ne répond qu'à une seule question
elle permet d'affirmer à peu près que ça
n'ait pas prévu ça n'est pas efficace
préventivement d'utiliser l'hydroxyde
chloroquine mais ça ne répond pas à la
question est-ce que l'hydroxyde
chloroquine peut avoir un effet curatif
les essais cliniques pour répondre à
cette question ne sont pas encore
terminées on aura les premiers résultats
la semaine prochaine et les politiques
ont eu tort de faire croire qu'on
n'allait faire des essais cliniques en
quinze jours c'est un mensonge comme
l'opinion était paniqué les politiciens
ont menti et on fait croire qu'on était
capables d'inventer de nouvelles
stratégies thérapeutiques en quelques
semaines ce n'est pas vrai aujourd'hui
il faut dire la vérité nous n'avons
toujours pas de traitement et il va
falloir probablement assez longtemps
pour qu'on ait des stratégies
thérapeutiques efficaces et c'est
important de finir les essais cliniques
aujourd'hui la première vague est
terminée à peu près mais on ne peut pas
exclure qu'il y ait une deuxième vague à
l'automne
il faut donc que nous soyons prêts et
que nous ayons des stratégies
thérapeutiques efficaces et pour cela il
faut faire des vrais essais cliniques et
pas des études contestables comme les
deux études de raul tu es il ya dix ans
les encadre et notamment on attend celle
discovery qui tarde à venir
l'étude européenne alors valérie boyer
valérie boyer est avec nous député les
républicains des bouches-du-rhône et
soutien inconditionnel de didier raoul
tu je me trompe vous ne soutenez pas non
mais la question n'est pas là on n'est
pas pour ou contre raul tancé par out
didier rahout n'est pas une équipe de
foot
moi je vous ai entendu valérie boyer le
défendre le soutenir à 2 sur de nombreux
plateaux est considéré que son
traitement marchait alors je pense que
vous excusez moi myriam en cas où vous
avez dû pas bien entendre ce que j'ai
dit moi j'ai témoigné en tant que malade
je ne perde pas de dire si son
traitement marchent marchent pas en
revanche ce que je note et j'étais cet
après midi ait lieu à chez eux pour
remercier les équipes soignantes pour
tout ce qu'elle a les faits pendant
cette crise épidémique et pour la
qualité de leur accueil de leur écoute
mais je pense que c'est pas c'est très
malsain de poser les questions en contre
en quoi cette cette controverse médical
sur la couleur hawkins hurle hydroxy
chloroquine au fond vous en saisissent
et d'une certaine façon en quoi la femme
politique que vous êtes participe de ce
débat là est ce que c'est un débat
politique franchement alors moi j'ai
témoigné en tant que malade je n'ai pas
la compétence médicale pour dire si ça
marche aussi ça marche pas en revanche
je voudrais avoir sur ce qui fonctionne
et sur ce qui ne fonctionne pas mais
vous avez une parole publique valérie
boyer vous êtes une aiguille j'ai d'être
réputé vous savez le scientifique
si vous témoignez votre parole n'a pesé
alors j'ai témoigné en tant que malade
je n'ai jamais dit que j'étais pour ou
contre la chloroquine nous
l'azithromycine c'est pas mon rôle
en revanche j'ai remercié les équipes
médicales du traitement que j'avais eue
mais aujourd'hui ce que je constate
c'est qu'on nous a promis des études qui
ne sont jamais là notamment discovery
notamment l'étude du chu d'angers qui
testait exact
le protocole de 10 des raouts et qui je
crois savoir s'est arrêté et que je me
pose aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi
n'attends pas de réponse
parce que après une semaine laurent
alexandre a expliqué que ça prenait ça
prenait évidemment voir beaucoup plus de
temps que finalement le temps
médiatico-politique vous avez laurent
alexandre expliqué que didier raoul tu
étais maintenant membre de la revue de
michel onfray front populaire c'est tout
c'est un engagement qui n'est pas donc
aux scientifiques cette fois ci qui
n'est pas médical vous souhaitez vous
souhaiteriez qu'ils s'engagent en
politique dudit raul tu sais moi vous
poser la question
valérie boyer écoutez ce serait pas le
premier médecin qui s'engagera en
politique par exemple ministre de la
santé il était engagé au parti
socialiste avant d'être engagée en
marche c'est votre question est quand
même très curieuse c'est une seule
condition qu'ils étaient engagés dans ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque les
républicains face à l'ump et c'est donc
c'est pas le premier homme politique
madame buzet s'est engagé à en marche
notamment dans vos réponses sur sur ceux
sur cette dimension politique est en
prêt en train de prendre cette
controverse
moi je leur en est l'exemple oui oui on
voit bien qu'il ya deux il ya deux axes
d'abord les populistes globalement aime
beaucoup aiment beaucoup à houlle
surtout depuis qu'il s'est rapproché
d'onfray et que l'on ferait a déclaré
que les gens qui étaient contre les
drogues si chloroquine est vendu aux
puissances de l'argent et puis d'autre
part on voit que il y à une
concentration des grands soutiens
politiques à raul tu dans la région paca
les sens sont là le pignon marseillais à
doha hoult elle mais il serait
extrêmement difficile et madame à madame
boyer quoi qu'elle pense de lutter
contre raul tu ce serait les tirer
contre son camp alors qu'on est en
pleine élection municipale dans la
région
merci merci beaucoup on va s'arrêter la
banque ont vraiment 10 secondes
on le retrouve ça ce soutien dans la
population plutôt à droite et à
l'extrême droite dans sur out on trouve
davantage de soutien pour didier rous
chez les sympathisants de france un sou
michal et deux passes sympathisants du
rassemblement national
et aussi je suis les sympathisants
républicains après tout les clivages ne
valent pas on a beaucoup voulu dire
c'est la province contre paris n'ont en
l'occurence c'est le nord contre le sud
le soutient didier rahout et il se
trouve plus dans le sud que dans le nord
mais il ya bien une dimension politique
dans tout ça c'est que maintenant
aujourd'hui des gens ont des convictions
sur hydroxy chloroquine co milliards il
en avait sur l'école privée le mariage
homosexuel immigration avant-hier sur l'
affaire dreyfus la géographie zola de la
chloroquine valérie boyer le mot de la
fin
mais je trouve je trouve que cette façon
dans les choses est complètement
incroyable je rappelle quand même que
ans à marseille pratiquement tous les
politiques locaux ce poids leur
étiquette leurs opinions ont été soignés
à liège où tout le monde
pratiquement tous ceux qui ont été
malades sont passés dans les mains du
didier rahout aujourd'hui la seule qui
pose deux questions pourquoi monsieur
véran le ministre de la santé qu'il
médecin était un engagement politique a
retiré l'hydroxyde roque sinde des
études dès la parution du lens est
pourquoi l oms
un coup c'est oui un coup c'est non et
pourquoi aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
réponse alors que plusieurs études ont
été lancées et moi je pense aux malades
comme gelée et et qui aujourd'hui se
pose des questions qui aujourd'hui sont
inquiets et j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on a
qu'on ait un débat apaisé et qu'on soit
pas là comme s'ils ont soutenu une
équipe de foot
ce sont quand même des personnes ce sont
des malades et puis vous reconnaissez
juste simplement pour nous quand vous
auriez pu vous avez pris de la
chloroquine vous êtes convaincu que ça
vous a permis de guérir
vous auriez pu aussi guérir sans vous
l'admettait mais vous n'êtes pas médecin
moi non plus moi quand je me suis
content quand j'ai été testée positive
on m'a proposé ce traitement j'ai été
hospitalisée jeu les prix après un
examen cardiaque après après un certain
nombre d'examens mais je trouve que ces
questions sont quand même incroyable
depuis le début de l'épidémie on le
demande
en tant que malade si je n'avais pas
pris de médicaments si j'avais guéri
comment voulez vous que je sache
aujourd'hui
d'abord est-ce que parce qu'il ya des
cas il ya beaucoup de cadres coville qui
ont guéri sans avoir pris de chlore
qu'il sait c'est un fait
artistiquement hospitalisé dix jours
j'ai eu un certain nombre d'examens et
j'avais un certain nombre de symptômes
qui était qui était pas anodin non plus
donc posé ces questions là je rappelle
que marseille c'est le seul endroit où
on a offert un parcours de soins aux
malades aujourd'hui nous sommes en train
de sortir de la crise sans avoir la
réponse est sans et et en laissant les
malades dans l'expectative
donc faut je vous rappeler que l'om et
pardonnez moi de vous interrompre à
décider quand même de reprendre les
essais cliniques avec avec la
chloroquine laurent alexandre et puis
vous aurez le mot de la fin d'un amour
emmanuel emmanuel rivière laurent
alexandre pour réagir oui je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut en attendant les
essais cliniques devenir plus
rationnelle faut dépolitiser cette
affaire mais c'est difficile candidat ou
et explique au journaliste de l'express
que la seule chose qui lui importe c'est
lé estime de lui même
on voit bien qu'on est dans une querelle
d'ego dans une querelle politique et que
finalement l'intérêt des malades est
moins important pour didier raoul que
l'estiment de lui même comme il l'a lui
même dit anne rachel journaliste à
l'express dont aujourd'hui il faut
revenir vers la vraie science la science
elle est laborieuse elle est lente
on prouve pas des nouveaux traitements
cinq minutes aux des mois et des mois
aujourd'hui un petit peu de patience il
faut faire confiance à olivier derand
qui je le prouve gère très bien cette
piste remercier et à essayer d'éviter au
maximum l'hystérie induite par le
comportement de didier rahout merci il
est déjà de roger des 6es débat lors
l'action parce que cette description de
la lenteur nécessaires pour aboutir à
des conclusions définitives va un peu à
l'encontre d'une idée un peu installé
chez les français quittent une autre
forme la guerre de la confiance dans la
science qui aurait dit comprennent pas
qu'on n'ait pas déjà les réponses et
c'est pour ça que s'engouffre assez
facilement tout a pas de soupçon
interrogations et finalement une
construction politique autour d'une
controverse scientifique ce fait elle
n'est pas terminée on prend pas qu'on ne
puisse pas avoir rapidement les réponses
parce que parfois le bon sens est assez
mauvais conseillers sur ces questions
merci beaucoup merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat à distance
allez c'est l'heure de ma journée à
l'assemblée
avec thomas des prêts qui nous raconte
une autre dispute c'est une bataille des
insoumis sur une proposition de loi qui
était débattu aujourd'hui sur les frais
bancaires ou exactement myriam c'était
aujourd'hui la niche parlementaire de la
france soumise une journée où les
députés insoumis fixe les textes à
l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée et une
proposition a été très débattu sur le
plafonnement des frais bancaires
je vous raconte ça jingle cette
proposition allait porter par alexis
corbière elle vise à plafonner les frais
bancaires 2 euros par incident 20 euros
par mois maximum 200 euros par an pour
tous les usagers quels que soient leurs
revenus
une disposition qui vise à maintenir le
pouvoir d'achat
je vais désormais présenter ma loi elle
s'adresse à tous pas seulement aux
clients en difficulté à tous rien ne
justifie ces frais d'incidents qui coûte
que quelques centimes à la banque et qui
sont facturés près de 15 euros
alan bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie et des finances étaient
présents ce matin dans l'hémicycle il a
répondu alexis corbière pas de soutien à
la proposition des insoumis mais il a
profité de l'occasion pour annoncer une
nouvelle réglementation sur les clients
dits à risques ce qui multiplie les
incidents bancaires
écoutez nous proposons qu'un client
soient considérés comme fragiles à
partir de cinq incidents banque est dans
une période d'un mois
la banque de france publiera la liste
des établissements qui ne se conforme
pas à l'engagement du plafonnement
nous allons donc mettre en place un
émane chem sur le plafonnement des frais
d'incident bancaire par les banques
françaises
alors que dit le rapporteur du texte des
annonces de bruno le maire on lui a posé
la question je râle exco verges
bon sans grande surprise le texte n'a
pas été adopté mais il a suscité le
débat tout au long de la journée
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir été entendus moi j'ai défendu
l'idée que le principe même de ces frais
bancaires qui coûte quelques centimes
aux banques mais qui vous sont facturés
parfois 15 euros 23 euros 50 euros quand
il s'agit d'un chèque supérieur à 50
euros qui est rejetée n'est pas
tolérable
voilà ce plafonnement que je proposais
doit s'adresser à tout le monde alors
certes il ya un travail qui est fait par
le gouvernement sur les publics les plus
fragiles et les plus en difficulté mais
même les classes moyennes j'en veux dire
qui sans être tout à fait de manière
confortable mais sont pas non plus en
grande difficulté je vois pas pourquoi
elles devraient se voir ponctionner ses
20 euros 50 euros etc
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
justifié ça c'est l'avis du rapporteur
du texte mais qu'en pensent les usagers
on a passé un coup de fil alors des
spécialistes des frais bancaires à l'ufc
que choisir
le fait de mieux définir les clients à
risque et de dénoncer les banques qui ne
jouent pas le jeu c'est une bonne chose
pour vous alors à ce stade aujourd'hui
c'est bien insuffisant dans la mesure où
nous souhaitons loi globale qui plafonne
les frais d'incident de paiement pour
l'ensemble des consommateurs et pas
simplement des mesures qui soient
curatives pour traiter la fragilité que
qui ont qui ont été engendrées par des
frais d'incident de paiement trop élevé
pour l'ensemble des consommateurs
du côté du ministère de l'économie et
des finances on indique que le décret
qui institue les nouveaux critères
communs à toutes les banques sera publié
au mois de juin et de son côté alexis
corbière dit qu'il restera vigilant et
qu'il n'hésitera pas à remettre le sujet
sur la table à l'occasion de prochaines
niche parlementaire
mais ça on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
dans ma journée à l'assemblée
voilà pour la chronique de tomate est
prêt on se quitte avec un nouvel épisode
de notre collection d'entretien dans le
jour d'après ce soir on parle de
l'éthique médicale avec frédéric
leicester flac
regardez
[Musique]
ça va bien ça va pas trop crevé va ça va
bonjour frédéric leicester flight les
jours on va revenir sur ses choix
tragique des médecins face à la pénurie
de ressources à l'hôpital mais d'abord
cette question personnelle qu'est
l'étrange situation pour vous la
chercheuse l'universitaire qui
travaillaient sur ces sujets c4
conscience depuis longtemps
qu'avez-vous ressenti au fond quand
quand cette forme de cauchemar est
devenu réalité mais c'est exactement ça
c'est mon cauchemar personnel ma névrose
personnel qui devient partagé par tout
le monde et ça fait très bizarre on est
quelques-uns à travailler sur ces
questions de deux choix d'arbitrage de
triage qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on
peut pas sauver tout le monde a qui vont
les ressources trop rares pour être
distribuée à l'ensemble de la population
et là d'un coup cette situation non
seulement elle devient notre lot
quotidien
mais surtout elle devient visible elle
est posée sur la place publique elle est
débattue par tout le monde et n'importe
qui et là évidemment les choses
deviennent tout à fait différent jusqu'à
présent c'étaient des questions dont
personne ne voulait entendre parler ou
alors dont on sent paraît avec disons le
le plaisir du sensationnalisme morale et
la maintenance et des questions
auxquelles on peut plus lui échapper
alors il ya des mots comme ça qui nous
assaillent par ce qu'ils renvoient de
presque d'épouvantables on parle de
pénurie on parle de réquisition on parle
aussi de rationnement et puis il ya ce
mot de tri de triage entre les vies
entre les malades vous allez nous dire
de quoi il s'agit précisément mais
d'abord à quoi il nous renvoie
qu'est-ce qu'ils réveillent en nous ce
mot de tri alors ce tri il est très
problématique parce que ce terme de tri
réveillent des démons du réveil des
anciens spectre trier entre lévis
apparaît à tout le monde une abomination
sa part est le comble de l'horreur moral
on devrait pas avoir à choisir les
sacrifiés et il ya tout un imaginaire
commun un imaginaire partagée de ses
choix tragique où il faut choisir qui on
sacrifie et à qui on accorde une chance
de surgy alors de quoi s'agit-il
à l'hôpital près
aisément ce qu'on appelle le tri dans en
urgence médicale collective se sont
annoncés d'un ensemble de procédés qui
consiste à pouvoir orchestrer des ordres
de priorité dans la prise en charge des
malades dans la prise en charge des
patients il faut préciser que ça a été
inventé sur les champs de bataille
napoléonien c'est l'arrêt le chirurgien
de napoléon qui a proposé cette idée de
trier les blessés non pas en fonction de
leur grade
c'est pas les officiers d'abord et les
simples soldats seulement si nous reste
des ressources
c'est en fonction de la gravité et de
leurs pronostics et donc sur un champ de
bataille quand on peut pas soigner tout
le monde en même temps quand on peut pas
prendre en charge tous les blessés
eh bien on cherche à maximiser le nombre
de vies sauvées et donc ça peut
entraîner des procédures où on ne peut
pas consacrer le temps et les ressources
nécessaires aux blessés les plus graves
qu'ils demanderaient à leur seul
bénéfice trop de temps et trop de
ressources déjà d'entrée de jeu
peut-être il faut le préciser ça ne
s'est pas produit ces situations de tri
à l'hôpital en france
même pendant le pic de l'épidémie il
faut il faut dissiper une ambiguïté du
tri il y en a tout le temps à l'hôpital
et en particulier les urgentistes les
réanimateurs pratiquer le tri couramment
ce que le tri pour eux ça signifie se
demandaient si le malade on le ramène
justifie une réanimation est ce que ça
fera sens de le réanimer ou est ce que
c'est une mauvaise décision c'est pas
toujours la bonne décision c'est pas
parce que c'est techniquement possible
qu'il faut le faire et qu'il est juste
de le faire donc du tri il y en a tout
le temps à l'hôpital il ya du tri sur
listes d'attentes quand vous arrivez aux
urgences en dehors d'un contexte de
pandémie
c'est pas premier arrivé premier servi
vous pouvez attendre cinq heures pour un
poignet foulé parce qu'il ya des cas
plus graves qui passe d'abord donc du
tri y en a tout le temps on peut pas
dire qu'on n'a pas pratiquer le tri on
pratique le tri tout le temps en
revanche ce qui s'est passé en italie
ce sont des situations différentes c'est
choisir entre deux vies a situation
sauvable égal décrivez-nous ce qui s'est
passé en lombardie notamment ceux dont
on a entendu parler en lombardie c'est
des services hospitaliers saturé c'est à
dire que des services hospitaliers
ou on peut pas prendre des nouveaux
patients et/ou du coup y'a on peut pas
étendre le stock de ressources
contrairement à ce que nous on a réussi
à faire à france c'est-à-dire transférer
des patients demandé dans d'autres
régions insaturés quand il ya saturation
et quand il ya plusieurs patients qui
arrivent avec un pronostic médical
équivalent comment est-ce qu'on arbitre
il faut pas laisser ça à l'arbitraire
des médecins en première ligne il faut
pas il faut appliquer des règles qui
soient justes qui tiennent compte de
l'équipe et c'est de là que le les
médecins italiens ont sorti un document
qui évidemment a causé un effet de
sidération mais un document d' de
recommandation il ya eu des critères qui
ont été posées et qui ont été appliqués
lesquels et avec quelle légitimité au
nom de quoi on peut décider que tel ou
tel critère est préférable à un autre
alors l'idée générale c'est l'équité et
la maximisation du bénéfice collectif
c'est à dire sauver le plus de vies
possibles sauver le plus de vies
possible ça signifie ne pas utiliser
dans un usage compassionnel des
ressources dont on est presque sûr
qu'elles ne serviront pas ça veut dire
quelqu'un qui a une très faible chance
de survivre à la réanimation
on n'essaie même pas et la difficulté
pour la perception publique de ce
problème c'est que l'un des des facteurs
de mauvais pronostic
l'un des facteurs qui qui fait que vous
allez avoir peu de chances de survivre à
la réanimation
c'est l'âge vous pensez que c'est à la
société de s'emparer de ces sujets là
qu'au fond il y à une sorte de débat
démocratique à avoir sur sur ces
critères là oui bien sûr qu'il ya un
débat démocratique à avoir il est
extrêmement compliqué il est extrêmement
coûteux pour la cohésion nationale c'est
très difficile de demander aux gens même
en dehors de la crise comment est ce que
la société doit penser sont finalement
son son protocole sacrificielle acquis
qui a priorité pour vivre quand tout le
monde ne peut pas vivre mais quelle
forme pourrait avoir ce débat une
consultation des citoyens à débat à
l'assemblée nationale
il ya toutes sortes de manières de faire
on peut
aux états unis ça fait des années qu'on
se prépare à la catastrophe en lançant
des exercices de public and get your man
sur ces sujets là donc c'est des
sondages qualitatifs ont ont fait jouer
aux citoyens le rôle de médecin trieurs
on leur décrit des cas il ya trois
patients qui arrivent en même temps ou
d'urgence et il reste plus qu'un lit à
qui vous l'accordé en fonction des
détails quand vous donne à mon avis ce
sont pas de bonnes manières de faire
parce que quand vous donnez un certain
nombre de détails sur des patients qui
arrivent en même temps aux urgences
ah et bien les détails que vous donnez
vous considérez d'emblée qu'ils doivent
avoir de l'importance
donc si vous donnez le métier vous
considérez que l'utilité sociale doit
avoir un rôle ce qui est pas du tout le
consensus aujourd'hui aujourd'hui tous
les documents sur le tri exclu l'utilité
sociale comme un critère valable
l'autre grand sujet qui interpelle à la
fois notre moral et puis au fond la
conscience collective c'est cesser ce
choix qu'ont fait pratiquement tous les
pays
le choix de sauver des vies au détriment
finalement de la casse sociale la crise
économique qui suivra forcément comment
vous analysé ce choix là qu'est ce que
ça dit de notre société est ce que la
valeur de la vie humaine a
considérablement augmenté je sais pas si
la valeur de la vie humaine a augmenté
ou si le passage à la puissance tragique
de ces sujets a balayé toute possibilité
d'une réflexion tout bénéfice
elle a pu avoir lieu ailleurs que chez
nous chez nous assez peu il me semble
que dans le risque d'une saturation des
services de santé des hôpitaux
il y avait comme une comme une vision
d'horreur morale qui était tellement
insupportable que on était prêt à tout
prix pour l'empêcher pour empêcher d'en
arriver là
maintenant il reste que les arbitrages
sur le déconfinement par exemple les
arbitrages sur remettre le pays en
marche
ou bien c'est pas renié
encore des afflux de patients et donc
des morts supplémentaires
ces débats suppose d'avoir des unités de
mesure commune et en économie de la
santé comme en éthique médicale dans
certaines traditions d'éthique médicale
on a des instruments pour mesurer ses
coûts bénéfices
on peut calculer par exemple
l'angleterre le fait couramment depuis
dans le cadre de son système de santé on
peut mesurer les années de vie
qualitatif sauver et donc on peut tout
faire rentrer dans un même programme de
mesures pour se demander comment
arbitrer mais vous personnellement
d'un point de vue moral vous pensez que
privilégier la vie humaine sur
l'économie c'est la première fois que ça
se fait à une aussi grande échelle dans
dans d'aussi nombreux états en cas
d'épidémie dans l'histoire des pandémies
c'est un progrès pour le dire autrement
est ce que la vie de milliers d'hommes
sauver valent plus au fond que celle de
ceux qui demain se retrouveront sur la
paille
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
c'est l'egypte qui risquait d'être le
plus perdu dans dans ce contexte de
pandémie c'est l égide de personnes
âgées ou des personnes fragiles et à
aucun moment on a fait un choix de
société qui aurait consisté à dire tant
pis pour eux tant pis pour les personnes
âgées au contraire on est sur un modèle
de société qui insiste sur le fait qu'on
ne veut pas sacrifier nos aînés qu'on
veut pas sacrifier deux personnes âgées
qu'on veut pas sacrifier nos personnes
fragiles et ce choix de société qu'on a
fait eh bien je crois que c'est aussi
quand même une raison de une raison
d'être fiers merci beaucoup merci
et ainsi s'achève cette émission merci
de votre fidélité à mardi prochain pour
un nouveau numéro de ça vous regarde
excellent grand week-end pour ce qui
entraîne et très belles stars
[Musique]